good evening
and welcome to this evening's full
council meeting
members of the public
i would like to remind you that in line
with the council's constitution
you are not able to speak or address the
meeting this evening unless you have
previously
submitted a public question
which forms part of this agenda
you are however welcome to listen and to
observe the business conducted during
this evening's meeting
please can i ask you to respect this and
to allow councillors to hear all the
contributions made during the course of
this meeting
so that they can make informed decisions
if anyone does interrupt the meeting
they will be asked to leave
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
i have received apologies from
councillor webb
and councillor wilson
council alumnly
councillor james newport
councillor lisa newport
and councillor reeves do we have any
further apologies
thank you
a agenda item 2 the minutes of the
meeting held on the 20th of july 2021.
members are you happy for me to sign the
meetings of the council held on the 20th
20th of july
agree agreed members thank you
agenda
and sorry agenda item three
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
i will assume agreement unless anyone
raises their hands no
members before we continue with the main
business of the meeting
i would like to move a motion without
notice in line with council procedure
rule 14c
to take item 12
asset delivery program next do i have a
second second actually thank you
can those in favor please raise their
hand and keep them up
while the officers count
as we take a vote
don't lower them until i ask you to do
so
please lower your hands
thank you members
okay can those against please raise your
hands right up and keep them up while
the officers count them
and don't lower them
until i ask you to do so
thank you members
you can now lower your hands
are there any abstentions
oh please lower your hands thank you
that was 23
for
one against
and seven abstentions thank you
so that motion is carried
members i would like to welcome richard
brooks from anthony collins solicitors
on my left
agenda item 12
the asset delivery program
members we have five public questions
relating to these items
there is a maximum of three minutes
available for
asking each question
first i will ask mr jim cripps to ask
his question to the leader of the
council
mr jim cripps would you please read out
the following question
good evening and thank you for the
opportunity to ask a question
it's directed at the council leader as
per protocol
but hopefully all the councillors
receive the message late and clear
my specific question relates to the
asset delivery program the new version
the report
and in particular
paragraph 3.6
which confirms
the council's ability to modify
the
specification
my question therefore is
can you please explain
why the covertly
prepared
scope pre-coded
and the output specification coming from
that
is being retained
despite
a clear 9-1 against public response in
the feedback
which was duplicated by our mp's opinion
and we're now moving into a postcoded
climate
of austerity
thank you
thank you mr crips
council autumn would you like to respond
to the question
thank you madam chairman and uh thank
you to mr crips for asking the question
the council's requirements for its
assets are rooted in its asset strategy
this strategy was developed via a member
working group process and approved at a
public meeting of the council in july
july 2018
this strategy articulates the council's
aims for its assets
these being to
regenerate and improve the local area
and facilities for local residents
provide high quality and sustainable
community and civic buildings
and reduce future costs
the member working party continued to
guide the program
a number of site visits workshops and
meetings were held with guidance
provided by the council's external
technical experts and officers
the council developed and approved the
outline business case for the program in
january twenty nineteen
setting out the financial benefits of
the program
it is a public document and is available
on our website
the output specification was developed
through a further series of meetings and
workshops with members officers and
technical advisors
it was approved by council in september
2019
the output specifications sets out the
ambition the council has for its new
operational buildings and the vision of
how the council will work going forward
that is an emphasis of mobile and
flexible working and the flexible use of
space for staff
members and the community
it also highlights the council's
requirements for environmentally and
financially sustainable
low maintenance
energy efficient buildings
the council carried out a comprehensive
engagement process and in the summer
published the responses received on its
voyage website
the council is now listening to that
feedback
as it said it would and reflecting how
that feedback can be reflected in the
proposals
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillorton
next i would like to call miss jill
please read out a question
for the leader of the council
thank you chairman and thank you again
for the opportunity
uh this is directed to the leader
as per protocol
will the leader commit to the mill arts
and events center also known as the mill
hall being removed from the asset
delivery program
will he commit to being removed from the
fusion leisure contract
being renovated and aligned to the
freight house brim levels which i
understand at the moment is good
and put out on a tender for an
experienced events company to manage and
protect rochester district's only
theater venue
thank you very much
thank you mr white
would you like to respond to the
question please
thank you madam chairman and thank you
miss waite for um your question
the mill arts and event center is
managed by a leisure contractor fusion
lifestyle the facility has been managed
under this contract by a number of
different partners since the contract
was first let
our current contractor and previous
operators of the facilities have
instigated various strategies to drive
up usage and revenue at the sites
however the facility remains financially
unsustainable
this council acted proactively to
identify the issue explore options and
create a plan for high quality
environmentally and financially
sustainable community facilities as set
out in the output specification and
business case approved by council
the site is the subject of this
evening's report and will be debated
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor
next would mr samantha reed please read
out your question for the leader of the
council once again uh thank you for
giving the opportunity to pose the
question
um
and my question is to the leader of
course
the mill hall was refurbished in 2003.
since then both fusion and the council
have failed to maintain this leisure
asset
allowing it to become dire and not fit
for purpose or as one councillor
commented very expensive toilets
was this deliberate neglect or systemic
failure to maintain this council asset
by officers and the executive
councillors to sell off our community
asset for development thank you
thank you miss raid
councillor wooden would you like to
respond
thank you madam chairman and again thank
you ms reed for uh your question
the mill hall was a big part in the mill
arts and event center has been managed
under contract by a leisure partner
since the contract was let approximately
20 years ago
during that time the building has
benefited from various capital works
however the building does not meet our
ambitions for low maintenance and high
energy efficiency coupled with low
operational costs
during the life of the building much has
changed in the leisure sector
however the council has remained
committed to working in partnership with
its leisure contractor to ensure they
invest and maintain the facility for the
benefit of the local community
it is a fact however that the leisure
market and use of the building has
changed and the facility has now become
financially unsustainable to operate and
does not support the ambition this
council has to become carbon neutral by
2030.
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor whitten
next i would like to invite mr john
payton to read out your question to the
leader of the council please
thank you for the opportunity and this
is directed to the leader thank you
regarding the proposed redevelopment of
the rayleigh civic suite and garden site
into commercial units and flat blocks
can the council address why there has
been no change in proposals despite
overwhelming public objection to the
proposals
the council appears to be ignoring
objections if they plan to proceed with
the civic suite plans
in the council's own engagement survey
for the civic suite
86
opposed the principle of redevelopment
89 of respondents oppose the current
proposals
the site is listed in the council's
spatial options document for potential
development essex county council place
services has advised through the spatial
options heritage assessment development
on this site will cause substantial harm
to a heritage asset
and proposals causing this level of harm
to the significance of a heritage asset
should be avoided
rayleigh town council has also stated in
its response to the spatial options
consultation that sites within the
existing rayleigh conservation area
should not be considered for development
in a recent bbc article the riley
institute of chartered surveyors stated
that due to the issue of embodied carbon
it is now promoting a refurbished first
policy to the government a campaign
backed by 14 sterling prize winners and
the role academy of engineering is an
agreement
the chartered institution of building
service engineers says we have to avoid
demolition and new build
the civic suite proposals means raley
will lose car parking space and green
space
rayleigh is the only tier one settlement
in the district and must have a civic
presence
this was agreed when rayleigh urban
council joined with rochard rule to
become rochford district council
the council should refurbish the civic
suite for continued council use
isn't it time this council abandons the
plans for the civic suite on behalf of
raley residents by acting on advice from
ecc and rayleigh town council and commit
to protecting the designated
conservation area
[Applause]
thank you mr payton
councillor wootton would you please
respond
thank you madam chairman and thank you
mr payton for your question
the council carried out an extensive
engagement process published the
feedback received and has been
reflecting on that feedback
with our partners we continue to
consider how this feedback could be
reflecting in the proposals
it is important to note that the
proposals the council shared during the
engagement process included the
remodeling of the council chamber
section of the civic suite building to
create a modern high quality office
space that could then support a local
business to grow or relocate and
therefore support the local economy
we take the feedback of statutory
consultaes very seriously as such this
feedback will be fully debated as part
of any future planning application
the scheme remains a proposal at this
stage
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillorton
would mr richard lamborn please reach
out the question
to the leader of the council
good evening and thank you for the
opportunity um can the lisa please
comment on as to why
the planning and legal departments
haven't had the resources or experience
to manage such a project
more proactively
saving considerable external costs as a
background when the council first
proposed the adp
it had a budget of 3.4 million
but of that
0.6 million was for professional fees
this is a massive 18
of the initial budget
should a council of rocha district size
be able to manage such
products projects in-house thus saving
the council taxpayer considerable
amounts of money especially in a project
where all the land is already owned by
the council
thank you mr lambeau
councillor would you like to respond to
the question
thank you again madam chairman and thank
you mr lamborn for your question
rocha district council is a small
authority with limited resources and has
not historically undertaken projects of
this magnitude
as such it would not be cost effective
or even possible to recruit and retain
the senior professional staff required
across a range of disciplines such as
project management legal and finance
with the required specialist knowledge
to support a program of this complexity
it is common for local authorities to
buy in this kind of professional support
for major projects for this reason
it would not provide value for money if
the required expertise was not brought
in as the financial risks of the program
fading or not achieving the required
outcomes over the longer term outweigh
those one-off project costs thank you
thank you councillor woodson
that completes the public questions
the responses for these will be included
in the minutes of the council meeting
and will also be sent out in writing to
the residents who have raised these
questions thank you
members we also have received
a number of member questions on notice
on this item
council and mrs mason can you please
read out councillor reeves question to
the leader
thank you
thank you
councillor
not just detaching
are we standing for questions or sitting
down
standing right there
could be taller even though i'm shocked
we'll go for it
um this is a question from councillor
adrian eves to the leader of the council
please explain following the widely
publicized leaflet at the election
earlier this year circulated by the
conservative party whether the asset
delivery program was officially paused
in any part as legally declared and if
so when and under whose authority
thank you councillor
councillor woodland would you like to
respond please
thank you madam chairman and um
it does seem a little odd responding to
council ahoy
on behalf of um who's acting on behalf
of councillor eve so please do not take
my comments that i'm going to read
absolutely personally because they are
directed towards council reeves
but firstly on a point of accuracy and
may i add not for the first time once
again councillor eves your question is
factually incorrect
where does it say on the leaflet asset
delivery program
from someone council reeves who on
record claims to hate politics and has a
strong belief in what is right
i find this question pretty rich
coming from someone who has called on
two occasions for the asset delivery
program to be paused
and i referred to the minutes of the 8th
of september page 5 where councillor
eaves moved a motion seconded by
councillor hawkway that the project be
paused and you can read for yourself
members
the detail of that minute
by asking the question there is an
inference that despite considerable
public feedback you would have carried
on regardless
against the background of considerable
concern
a promise was made in that leaflet to
listen
review and reflect on feedback from the
engagement process
and that was confirmed in a council
press release on the 22nd of september
issued in my name
there has been a pause and as an
administration we have listened and are
taking action accordingly
tonight is a stage in the process
if that is a crime then i'm guilty as
charged thank you
thank you councillor witton
council ahoy do you have a supplementary
question i'm not sure it's appropriate
for me to have a supplementary thank you
councillor wilkinson can you please read
out your question to the leader
thank you chairman it's a shame
councillor is not uh councillor eve is
not here because i'm sure he'd have a
lot to say in response
however i'll move on
tonight's agenda we're talking about the
update position of the asset delivery
program in light of public feedback
with the exception of the officers
report and the terms of reference for
the partnership panel the documents
which accompany the report and those
with the details of what options are
are marked as commercially sensitive
and not to be shared with the public
police can the leader of the council
explain to this council and more
importantly to the members of the public
who are present precisely why the public
are being excluded from hearing the
amended plans the council has come up
with which the council will be expecting
members to vote on tonight without being
able to seek any feedback from their
ward residents beforehand thank you
thank you councillor wilson
wilkinson sorry
councillor wooten
would you like to respond
thank you
madam chairman and thank you councillor
wilkinson for your question
the council is under a contract with gb
partnerships exempt appendix 1 is a
revised scheme proposed by
gb further to feedback from the public
engagement exercise and it is their
obligation under the contract to meet
the requirement of the council's output
specification
the information in the appendix is
commercially sensitive and is exempt
under the 1972 act because it is
information relating to the business
affairs of gb partnerships
if agreed a formal planning application
would be submitted and it would be will
be subject to formal statutory
consultation under the planning process
appendices two and three
uh
appendices two and four are exempt
because to release the information would
compromise the council's ability to
negotiate effectively and protect the
council's commercial position under
contract thank you thank you
councillorton
councillor wilkinson would you like to
read out your question
uh i'd like a supplementary question to
my first please check
um thank you chairman um
i've looked up
um what commercially sensitive means and
i do accept that i'm not
a lawyer in that field so i will stand
be corrected but what i've discovered is
that the commercial incentive is is
defined as information that's a rival in
the marketplace who obtains access to uh
it could be harmful so examples such as
information client lists tender
documents pricing documents technical
drawings and plans etcetera
now to my knowledge chairman and please
correct me if i'm wrong there's nobody
else involved in this there's only gb
partnerships there's no other
business involvedness whatsoever so no
other organization is going to gain
access to this so i i don't understand
why this commercially sensitive
um and
to be quite frank with you i i think
this is um
dangerous ground bearing in mind the
backlash that we received or the council
received uh in may this year or sorry
earlier than may this year when the the
plans uh were released and we had the
webinar
um and uh
you know
because there'd be no public
conversation beforehand um they the um
the public um didn't like the options
that we're coming up with so i'll say in
the morning on that but i there's no
other company involved so i don't see
why it's commercially sensitive thank
you councillor wilkinson did you have a
question a supplementary question
uh not to that chairman no i thought
thank you would you like to read out
your following question then
okay so thank you in relation to
tonight's agenda we'll be discussing the
asset delivery program can the leader of
the council please assure members of
this council members of the public that
he has not tied this council into any
contract with either gb partnerships or
any other organization for that matter
that in the events that we as a council
decide to abandon the project as a whole
or any part of that project resulting
from public opinion
there will not be penalties to us either
financial or otherwise can you give us
his assurance that we can vote this
evening with confidence that we will not
be penalized by a gp partnership in the
events that for example we decide to
vote for option two
thank you councillor wilson wilkinson
councillor
thank you madam chairman and thank you
councillor wilkinson
appendix iv sets out the legal
implications and the risks of pursuing
the options are in the public report
as with any commercial contract there
are express provisions to allow one
party to terminate the contract without
the other being left financially
disadvantaged if we choose to abandon
the project as per councillor
wilkinson's words there would be
abortive costs payable
this is not deemed to be a penalty per
se as there is no breach of contract
the contract was approved by council on
the 8th of september 2020 and attached
to the report thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson will wootton and
councillor wilkinson do you have a
supplementary question i do and i have a
question this time chairman
um thank you to the leader we've been
assured throughout this process uh that
the contract which was awarded to gb
partnerships is non-binding
on us in other words we still have the
option to stop the projects entirely
why then are we as members being told
that they are likely to be financial
implications whatever term you wish to
apply to it if we decide not to proceed
with the project or in this case even
amend the project um and i i'm not going
to quote obviously because it's exempt
but the legal advice even talked about
the fact you've asked your question
thank you
well i haven't actually
i've still i've still got further to add
okay thank you
it is clear to me the contract that has
been agreed between gb partnerships and
rochefort council allows an expectation
for gb partnership that they will be
developing these sites
it is simply a case of what they will be
doing and the council has not agreed to
that how does the leader here's my
question how does the leader then
explain
that if members were to choose option
two this evening a huge amount of public
money could be wasted on compensating
junior partnerships
[Music]
thank you council wilkinson thank you
madam chairman um
thank you councillor wilkinson
you know i really do get a little
confused when we do what i pledge we
would do and that is actually sit back
and listen to the
1133 responses we had to the public
engagement process
and then
you try and put us into a corner by then
criticizing what we're actually doing
and
may i
suggest madam chairman that
we really do have questions rather than
long-winded statements thank you thank
you
would you like to read out your question
to the leader please thank you chairman
again another question to the leader of
the council
i apologize for the lengthiness of it
as part of a heritage risk review
historic england
to complete an updated appropriate
survey of its conservation areas
highlighting conditioned threats and
trends
the surveys identify conservation areas
that are deteriorating or in a very bad
or poor condition and not expected to
change significantly in the next three
years has been defined as at risk rdc
received this request on the 18th of may
2021
rdc did not respond to the survey as
their resources have been focused this
summer on work towards preparing a new
local plan
this is what we were told the last
surveys of the district's conservation
areas were carried out in 2007.
raleigh conservation area survey states
raleigh castle is a scheduled ancient
monument protected under the 1979
ancient monuments act
brady castle is an important it's
important as an historic monument the
only significant public open space and
amenity in the conservation area and as
a wildlife haven
the outer baylor of rainey castle is
today occupied by the mill hall the
windmill and associated car parking the
middle hall 1971 is a large functional
regular community building incorporating
a theater
and a cafeteria
will the
leader explain sorry it says council but
it does mean the leader he explained why
they didn't implement radio conservation
management proposals
um one the entrance by the middle hall
needs to be given greater emphasis and
presence and needs to be advertised by a
better position to notice build the idea
canvas being the conservation plan to
recreate the barbican entrance is an
exciting one the space in front of the
middle hall on bellingham lane is a
prominent one at the edge of this group
of public buildings and the monument
and
and the monument is laid out with
sculpture and planting and has the
potential to be a piazza this is from
the
report
will the leader commit to completing a
new comprehensive survey of all
conservation areas and will the count
the leader sorry the leader accept their
own conservation survey states that the
mill arts and event center is classed as
a theater
thank you councillor hi
[Applause]
councillor wootten would you like to
respond please
thank you madam chairman and uh thank
you uh councillor hoy for your three
questions there um and um if i just go
back uh to uh point e i think uh and i
will just go through them in in order
and say well will the leader explain why
they didn't implement ready conservation
management proposals the answer to that
particular question is that the radi
conservation area appraisal and
management plan document was
commissioned to serve as part of the
evidence base for the local development
framework as it stood at that time
the proposals themselves do not
represent council policy but are
aspirational and the level of detail set
out in the proposals was not adopted
into the planning policy documents nor
would it be usual to do so
i then go on to
your second question at point f
and as a reminder and will the leader
commit to completing a new comprehensive
survey of all conservation areas and the
answer is the need to review the
evidence base for the conservation area
will be considered as part of the
current local plan review
it is too early to conclude whether new
surveys of the conservation areas will
be required
and your third question
at point g
and will the leader accept their own
conservation survey states the mill arts
and event center is classed as a theater
and i refer you by way of answer to page
36 paragraph 10.64
of the 2007
conservation area plan
the documentation states the mill hall
is a large functional community building
incorporating a theater and a cafeteria
this statement does not suggest that the
building should be classed as a theatre
any more than it suggests it should be
classed as a cafeteria
rather it is merely an observation of
functions being served within the
setting of a community building thank
you council ohio thank you madam
chairman thank you councillor
council lahore you have a supplementary
question i just have one supplementary
question to keep it short um
this is going to be on the final one
about the classification of theater
clearly i've asked that for a reason
which i'm sure cats that would knows why
um
there were changes in classifications of
planning in 2020
the mill hearts the mill arts and event
center was classified
as d2 which encompasses theaters cinemas
etc
theaters cinemas etc
according to planning should be
reclassified when d2 was abolished
should be reclassified as sue generous
which i'm sure we all know we've done
planning however some reason it's been
classified as f2
can please explain why this council
chose to
reclassify the mill arts and event
center
which was d2 as f2 rather than sue
generous
thank you council lahoy
would you like to respond to council
thank you madam chairman uh thank you
council ahoy um you've had the benefit
of doing a little bit more research on
your supplementary than i've had in
being able to give you an effective
reply um but it's a fair question that
deserves a fair answer and i will ensure
that officers do
come up with an appropriate reply which
will be published on our website as well
thank you very much indeed
sorry
my request is sent to all members as
well please certainly yeah absolutely
thank you
and thank you for that question
councillor stanley can you please read
out your question to the leader
thank you chairman uh to the leader um
regarding the
proposed redevelopment of iranian civic
suites
and the mill hall and garden site
into commercial units and flat blocks
can the leader address why there has
been no change in proposal despite
overwhelming public objection to the
proposals
[Applause]
thank you councillor stanley councillor
wooden
madam chairman uh thank you council
stanley for your question and actually i
thought tonight was a stage in the
process that we were going through um to
actually address the points but i will
more formally respond to you and say
that i
welcome this opportunity to have the
debate
and answer your question at the outset
of this process as leader of rochford
district council i made a promise that
we would listen to all representations
made regarding the proposals
and i do want to emphasize the point
they were proposals
and i also want to make the point that
people at the time said that we would
just railroad this through
we're not
we're listening
as i said earlier
1133 responses predominantly
on the radio side deserve to be listened
to
and that is exactly what we're doing
the council said it would carry out an
engagement process and that is what we
did
the council also said it would publish
the feedback we received and it also met
that commitment
the council also committed to reflecting
on that feedback and that is what we are
doing
with our partners we continue to
consider how this feedback could be
reflected in the proposals as they
evolve
thank you councillor stanley thank you
thank you council orton council stanley
do you have a supplementary question to
ask
thank you chairman um it's nice to hear
that from the from
the leader of the council however
and i realized that uh the leader of the
council is uh
uh taking notice of of public opinion
and i welcome that entirely however
there are
certain aspects where there is a little
bit confusion from the council to the
public as to
what is happening next and and i'm sure
that the leader will
endeavor to uh publicize that in the
future thank you
was that a question
there's no question to ask them it's not
a question it's it's a statement you
only get a question well the question is
the question is
when will uh does the leader anticipate
when the sorry i'm not standing
when the uh announcement will be made in
in due course
council lawton are you able to answer
that
thank you madam chairman and thank you
councillor stanley for your
supplementary question and we live in an
era don't we where uh we want to know
the next stage of the process before
we've dealt with the current phase so as
i said a little earlier
we are in a process uh tonight depending
on how the debate goes and how the vote
goes at
item 12 will really determine
what is the next phase of the process
so
i think you've got to wait for the
excitement to come a little bit later on
in the in the meeting but i made a
pledge that we would listen
we've heard uh comments from um the
public
and
a lot of those comments have been
extremely constructive
and i welcome those comments
and
if you ask for feedback it would be
disingenuous not to listen to that
feedback but at the same time members
i've got to say that the council has to
look at its assets it has to make sure
they're cost effective it has to make
sure that it meets the community need
and i actually believe that what we have
got here is an exciting program albeit
the call from residents particularly on
the raidy side is that we need to have a
look at it again
to see what we can do
to come up there's no point in listening
to people or
asking people to engage if we don't
listen to them what the outcome will be
i can't tell you at the moment um but i
am committed to a open transparent and
honest process i can't offer you more
than that thank you council stanley
thank you thank you councillor whitten
members we have one motion on notice
and this item was proposed by councillor
eves do we have another to stand in on
behalf of
uh thank you madam chairman um i will
counsel you mrs mason thank you yes with
your permission madam chairman
i will for allowing me to speak for
council reeves who is
recovering from an operation and i sure
would have wanted to be part of this
debate
and put his view here tonight
but his motion is
following the leaders announcement
regarding the future of the mill hall
that this council agrees to there being
cross-party involvement
in discussion and formation
or sensation of plans and proposals for
the mill hall site going forward
thank you councillor mrs mason is that
your proposed are you the proposal that
is the motion from councillors and
you're proposing that are you i thought
i was quite clear yes thank you and do
we have a seconder
thank you councillor hi
are you
able to answer that
oh sorry okay
do it do we have any
questions
no debate yeah council overton
i was just wondering whether council
ahoy was going to speak now or
or
as a seconder i wonder whether the
council
okay you reserve the right to speak
thank you
so if i may be the
first speaker with your permission
um
and it is slightly odd um speaking
without the proposer actually here and
certainly we wish uh councillor eves
well soon
so
i hope he soon is back to good health
and his
normal self
if i may say madam chairman this motion
smacks of council reeves's his personal
eagerness and rather desperate attempts
to make a name for himself politically
why would i or this administration
support a superfluous and unnecessary
motion for something already agreed and
already in place
the reported item 12 provides two
options for the mill arts and events
center site
if option 2 is agreed it is proposed
that the partnership panel will play a
significant part in the development of
the separate outline business case for
the mill arts and event center site
working with officers and advisors to
formulate the options analysis
and section 5 of the report at item 12
page 12.5
sets that out very clearly and very
specifically
it is proposed that the partnership
panel will therefore meet not only to
continue their good work on the program
but specifically to participate in this
new community center work stream
the partnership panel is cross party
and will be supported by senior council
officers and external advisors as
necessary
effective cross-party arrangements are
already in place in the form of the
partnership panel
and the council with their own terms of
reference
and governance mechanisms
and i will not therefore be supporting
this motion simply because those
mechanisms are already in place
thank you madam chair thank you
councillor will wootton
council of dry
thank you my manager
excuse me councillor dre i don't think
your microphone's on
i'll start again thank you madam
chairman
i agree and support the words of
councillor wootton and would emphasize
that the partnership panel will continue
to be chaired by an elected member and
will continue to be cross party and be
supported by senior council officers and
external advisors as required
as such and as chairman of the
partnership panel i will not be
supporting this motion
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor dre
councillor wilson wilkinson i'm sorry
i know 12.
my apologies
thank you chairman
um
it's interesting to listen to the
comments from both councillor dre and
councillor woodson mike is this working
for me yeah it is working
um because i need to remind the leader
of a conversation he and i had um after
the election um when i and i'm sure all
your group's aware of this because he
said that he went back to all and spoke
to you about this when i said
why isn't the independence group got a
seat on this panel which we had before
we had one in conjunction with the then
green group
and i was told that the conservative
group won't support it so when you talk
about cross party i'd like to remind you
all there are four political groups in
this council not three
the independent group consists of myself
and councillor lawrence both of whom are
representatives of wheatley ward in
which the main contentious assets sit
and yet we are not allowed
a seat on this panel we're not allowed
to say in this project at all i've asked
and i've asked and i've asked and
the lead is nodding his head because he
knows i've spoken to him and we've been
refused access to this panel other than
as an observer
so i do support this motion because this
is not cross party this is purely and
simply pro rata
where the number of seats have been
decided being seven so the conservatives
have five liberal democrats have won the
rochester rochester district residents
have one what about the independent
group why don't we get one so it's not
cross party thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson
councillor stanley
put your name down
thank you madam chair uh it's strange
talking to a motion um where the
proposal isn't here and
perhaps counsellor mason doesn't
actually have the information i see but
bearing in mind the comments from the
leader perhaps it would be worth an
explanation
as to um how counselor eve sees this new
working group working with the existing
partnership panel
um as uh whilst i don't know council
loses as well as council orton i i i'm
not sure i agree with his suggestions on
motivation on this thank you
thank you councillor canel
do we have any other speakers wishing to
speak
okay well we're going to take this to
the vote then
oh sorry yes you've got the right to
speak
councillor
thank you chairman
um it's always difficult
speaking to emotion you didn't propose
um i take on board the comments made by
councillor wootton
however i think there's a
as councillor wilkinson said i think
they we see things slightly differently
from this side and also there is the
the point about the partnership bald as
well
so
the the motion is talking about
cross-party
working panel which is different to the
working panel
which
councilor wooden is referring to for
which we have seen this terms of
reference
which is a pro rata
working group which is effectively a
sub-committee of the council
um at the moment there's no
representative on the board which makes
the decision that this is purely officer
based decision making
and
we feel that the there should be a
working group which feeds into that at
the very least i mean it can be a
partnership panel it can be something
else but the board is undemocratic as we
see it
and that's why we're proposing this
motion thank you
thank you councillor hi
[Applause]
members we will now vote on this motion
please raise your hand in favor and keep
your hands up so that the officers can
count
okay i'll stand for a recorded vote
yes it's a recorded vote
cancel mrs butcher for against abstain
please